Speaker 1: Moving on to other things, how
about covid?
Right, covid horrible all across the country.
But as usual, I want to start right down here
in my home state of Florida where, as we know.
Our trump loving Republican Governor De Santurce.
Has said and they doubled down again on this
on Friday, that any school district.
That implements a massive mandate, which is
a growing number of them at this point, we
may cut off your funding.
Now, according to reports on Friday, and this
really angered me because these reports are
totally inaccurate, they said that DeSantis
had backed off.
His claim to cut the salaries of administrators
who go along with these mass mandates, instead,
what actually happened was you had DeSantis
D.A. spokesperson Christina Pusha, who came
out and said, we're going to leave it to the
to the school boards to voluntarily give up
their salaries for doing this once we cut
their funding.
So they didn't exactly back off it.
They just realized, oh, wait, we actually
don't have the authority to do it.
So we're going to explain how it can be done,
but we're still going to cut off your funding,
they said.
So over the weekend, the Biden administration
came out, did the right thing and said, hold
up now.
Any school district in the state of Florida.
Oh, and before I even get into that, Biden
actually called some of the districts and
thanked them for putting mass mandates in
place.
So that was a good job as well.
Biden is not backing down off this.
He is making sure that these people know he
has their back.
And so after the phone calls, his administration
came out and said anywhere in the state of
Florida, if they cut off your funding for
having a massive mandate, we got your back
and we'll make sure you get the funding.
If we have to, we will use some of these covid
emergency funds to fund your school district,
to pay your salaries, to do whatever we need
to do, because we're not going to let this
Florida tyrant.
Tell you to make these horrible decisions
that could put your kids in danger.
Across the state, in county after county,
including counties that defied to Santas and
did put mass mandates in place, we are seeing
record numbers of teachers, administrators
and students out with covid or having to quarantine
because of exposure.
Broward County, I think the number was, what,
440 out?
You also had four teachers in Broward County,
all died last week within hours of each other
from covid.
Reopening these schools with no mask mandates
at all, no vaccine mandates for teachers or
administrators was one of the biggest mistakes
we have seen this this state do.
You know, last year.
They started doing away with the virtual learning,
with the distance learning, forcing most people
to go brick and mortar this year, distance
learning was not even an option.
It was brick and mortar or you become a full
time home schooler.
And that's why we're seeing so many problems.
We we didn't we didn't have the option.
We weren't given a choice.
The only choice we have is whether or not
we personally send our kids to school wearing
a mask, which, yes, I have done.
When I dropped them off, they have their masks
on when I pick them up, they still have their
masks on.
I have no idea what happens all throughout
the day, though, with those masks.
Are they taking it off as soon as I drop them
off, are they putting it on when they see
me walking up?
I don't know and I don't know what any of
the other children are doing there either,
except I do know when I go to pick them up
in the afternoon, there's only a handful of
kids wearing masks.
And I've only seen one staff member wearing
a mask when I've gone to pick up my children.
One.
This situation is about to become so much
worse.
We're now a full week down, hundreds of people
throughout the state as a result of exposure
at school, either on quarantine or.
Out with covid.
And it's going to get worse as time goes on,
because we're not protecting our kids, DeSanto
said he left the decision up to the parents.
Well, the parents aren't making the right
decision here.
And they're letting their kids get exposed,
who then expose other children, all we have
to do is have our kids wear masks.
They had to do it all throughout the school
year last year.
You know, many problems it caused.
None.
There were no reports of any child being injured
from having to wear a mask.
There was not mass hospitalizations because
children's oxygen levels dropped due to wearing
a mask.